non
[Musique]
ambiance bavaroise à four que ce samedi
1er juin la quatrième édition de la fête
de la bière pour célébrer le jumelage
avec la ville allemande de chelm ya de
la bière qui viennent d'allemagne des
saucisses brad bird qui sont la vienne
aussi d'allemagne qui sont livrés par
nos amis allemands et c'est toute
l'équipe de l'association d'une halle
lundi créé cet événement qui organise de
tous l'objectif c'est de passer un
moment au sol et de promouvoir l'échangé
franco-allemand vingt ans d'amitié
franco-allemande au niveau local un
partage culturel de l'art de vivre
autour de la bière produite directement
hblm ceylac rembarre pis c'est une bière
locale qui est brassée à côté de cheval
mas et ses neveux pils une variété de
pils légèrement une pointe d'amertume
voilà une des figures voilà est un peu
un peu un peu de mousse
quand même tourné dans ce village depuis
30 ans mais on vit tous aux états unis
et on est chez nos parents sauce pas
aujourd'hui on s'est rendu compte qu'il
y avait cette petite fête dans le
village ce qui fait quand même assez
plaisir de pouvoir se retrouver ici
comme ça en famille autour d'une bière
sans être en bas en allemagne
elle est très bonne c'est une bière de
soif allemande on est dans l'ambiance
bilan de ces festivités 300 bruxelles
mills aussi c'est près de 500 bières
vendues tout cela avec modération bien
sûr